as of late the horror genre has seemed
to receive a renaissance Resident Evil 7
follows a new formula laid out by silent
hill's PT a demo for again which sadly
we will never get to play but anyway
this mantle has well and truly been
picked up by a multitude of survival
horror games hitting PlayStation PC and
Xbox / 2017 we are trying to pick a
horror game to play on the channel and
I'm hoping you can help us decide anyway
here's our Pick of seven of the best
horror games still to come in 2017
okay so I really made this list so I
could talk about Friday the 13th I'm
sure you've heard of the horror
franchise and the gruesome serial killer
Jason this concept started back in the
1980s but is now receiving a video game
that is both a scary and as vicious as
the movies there was a Commodore 64 game
in the mid 80s which was scary but for
very different reasons Friday the 13th
is primarily an online game where
several players will play as a set of
young campers enjoying spring break and
the other player well they will play as
Jason and their job is to hunt down an
attempt to murder everyone who inhabits
Crystal Lake the sphere when hiding from
a machete-wielding man monster is enough
to give me the heebie-jeebies originally
the game was intended to be released in
2016 but was pushed back to this year to
allow for a single-player campaign
personally that is a delay I am more
than happy with as a single-player
campaign will be a great addition to
this title youngji thing the next title
which will try to cheer you to the core
is village which looks like a spiritual
successor to Silent Hill PT slowly
creeping around a house a freakin huge
house I might add seemingly helpless
that doesn't appear to be weapons or
defensive items so those inevitable jump
scares and long build-up sequences of
suspense will hurt you all the more even
the sound of your own footsteps will
scare the hell out of you with this
house
elements of the Slenderman game seem to
pop up and those children's sketches
unnerved the best of us oh and this was
a Kickstarter project so I salute anyone
who supported it agony is a survival
horror game that takes place in hell you
probably think of fire and brimstone
but agony tries to show you an
alternative health filled with tormented
Souls and abouts of amnesia which
usually goes quite well with horror
games you have the ability to possess
lesser minded demons which seems to be
the core difference between this game
and others on the list as you attempt to
escape hell and I'm guessing you'll
probably change your mind once you
finally figure out what you did to be
sent there in the first place
you probably heard about last two it's
another horror game which had a great
deal of attention only Resident Evil
seem to have marbles at the start of
2017 the demo is available to download
now and I recommend doing so but if you
don't want to do that you can watch me
and James playing it instead shadow
what's up Flickr what's that what's that
Flickr what is that outlast offers no
way to fight your enemies therefore you
must run around you must be stealthy you
must keep away from everyone you find
regularly hiding under beds in lockers
anywhere you can fix this is coupled
with a video camera which helps you see
in very low light but the batteries
constantly need replacing which prompts
the player to move quickly and feeds
into the fear of the unknown the first
title was definitely a masterpiece and
this second game looks to build a
partner hello neighbor is only available
on the PC but the developers have hinted
at ps4 and Xbox one versions a little
down the line of course in this title
you play the young boy who wants to know
what his shifty neighbor is hiding in
his house don't be fooled by the art
style this may look approachable but
this is a tense title involving stealth
planning quick reactions and an escape
route back to your home trying to look
around the house without your neighbor
catching you can give you palpitations
here's the kicker for this title each
time you try to enter the house or
change your method the AI will learn and
put traps there and move objects to
prevent you from using the same strategy
more than once basically this game
learns how you play and adapts
accordingly if that doesn't give you the
chills I don't know what will
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's give the psvr a chance to shine
the persistence is set on board of
spaceships called yeah you guessed it
the persistence in the year twenty five
twenty one while conducting a major
experiment on a black hole a horrific
incident occurs mutilating many of the
crew this one is a sci-fi survival title
but in virtual reality if you've played
Resident Evil in VR or any horror game
for that matter you will understand the
sheer horror of playing these titles
with a headset on it's also possible for
other players to scare the SH excreme'
out of the survivor are using an app on
your phone or tablet to interact with
the ship meaning each playthrough will
be completely different if your friends
are on hands
finally little nightmares is the lowest
costing game on this list retailing at
around 16 pounds in the UK and $20 in
the US it's a side-scrolling platformer
which won't scare you in the same way as
the other titles on this list but
navigating through the puzzle and
avoiding the freakish characters is
definitely a little unnerving the game
itself even says it is sure to deliver
eerie chills and goose bumps and for
that price and for that aesthetic I'm
going to give it a try so that's it
that's seven horror titles for you to
flip this year which do you recommend
and what would you like to see on our
channel if you're not a subscriber then
now is a great time to do so and you
will be sharing the channels content for
the future I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade and I can't wait to be scared to
death see you next time
you
[Music]